donc je suis un spécialiste de la Chine
et pas spécialiste des aspects
techniques de la désinformation donc
qu'il s'agisse de des informations enfin
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je vais surtout essayer de vous
éclairer
sur sur le contenu et comment comment
d'une manière générale les pratiques
informationsnelles chinoises se
déploient que ce soit sur Tik Tok ou
d'autres plateformes parce que le
problème est pas fondamentalement
différent finalement
ce qu'il faut peut-être commencer par
rappeler c'est que
l'application
TikTok ne recueille pas davantage de
renseignements sur ces utilisateurs que
d'autres applications du même type et
alors là c'est ce que j'ai pu lire parce
que moi je suis spécialiste de ces
questions là mais moins que facebook
même par exemple
donc la question c'est pas tant
finalement en tout cas c'est pas
seulement la question de la quantité de
données ou la nature des données qui
peuvent être collectées par Tik Tok et
infinés par by dance donc ça la maison
mère chinoise mais plutôt la nature du
régime politique entre les mains duquel
c'est informations pour arriver un
régime autoritaire s'il en est le régime
chinois
une autre distinction peut-être
importante et celle de la nature des
utilisateurs il y a sans doute une
distinction à faire entre
nuancerai après mais il y a quand même
une distinction à faire entre des
utilisateurs dont les activités
professionnelles
représentent un intérêt pour la Chine et
donc peuvent constituer des cibles du
Parti communiste chinois et les
utilisateurs disons lambda qui
n'ont pas de représentent pas en tant
que tel d'intérêt pour le PCC même s'ils
peuvent faire l'objet collectivement
d'opérations de désinformation ou
d'influence menées par le parti
donc ce que je vous propose c'est de
passer en revue un certain nombre de
points durs de questions qui
émergent dans les dans les médias
d'activités disons inquiétantes à tout
le moins de la part de Tik Tok
alors c'est pas exhaustif mais ça permet
d'illustrer en quoi c'est un problème en
quoi l'application peut poser problème
d'abord il y a eu un certain nombre de
révélations c'est c'est trois dernières
années
a commencé par une opération
d'espionnage
de contrôle ils ont de suivi deux
journalistes par bidens
cette affaire a été révélée par
différents médias à la suite
d'enregistrement audio qui ont fuité
depuis Tik Tok c'est à peu près 80
heures d'enregistrement qui ont été
ainsi diffusés et qui ont été analysés
par par les médias notamment qui ont
travaillé sur sur cette question
notamment BuzzFeed et qui ont montré que
les un certain nombre de un certain
nombre d'utilisateurs américains
les données disons d'un certain nombre
d'utilisateurs américains étaient entre
les mains
d'utilisateurs de by dance donc de
personnel de l'entreprise by dance en
Chine et non pas de personnel de TikTok
ailleurs hors de Chine or toute la la
défense de Tik Tok qui est bien illustré
par le projet que l'entreprise a mis en
place récemment un projet Texas donc de
stockage des données utilisateurs
notamment aux États-Unis
et à Singapour donc en dehors de Chine
en tout cas
cette affaire a montré que cela n'était
pas vrai donc puisque des membres de by
dance affirmait eux-mêmes dans ses
enregistrements qu'ils avaient accès aux
données
ces premières informations ont été un
point de départ d'enquête menée par
différents médias
journaux d'investigation américain et
qui ont révélé qu'en fait
en partie une partie disons des
Américains qui avaient été suivis
par bidens étaient des journalistes qui
s'intéressaient à Tik Tok
et ce qui est intéressé particulièrement
bidens c'était de savoir s'il ne pouvait
pas croiser les données de
géolocalisation de ces journalistes avec
des employés de Tik Tok pour identifier
qui était responsable des fuites au sein
de la société donc qui avait parlé
aujourd'hui donc c'est ça qui est
intéressé essentiellement dans cette
affaire en tout cas
l'entreprise l'entreprise chinoise
donc d'une manière générale
on peut pas
accorder beaucoup de crédit
à Tik Tok quand l'entreprise nous dit
que les données restent aux États-Unis
ou en tout cas hors de Chine que la
frontière entre bydens et Tik Tok et
étanche et qu'aucune donnée ne peut être
exploitée par la partie chinoise de
de du groupe
deuxième problème que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure également c'est celui de
la censure donc la censure sur les
contenus Tik Tok
alors bien sûr peut-être une première
remarque pour nuancer un petit peu
la censure dont on parle sur TikTok n'a
rien à voir avec la censure qui existe
sur les autres sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois en Chine et a commencé par
drawing qui est donc la version chinoise
de de Tik Tok où là la censure est
complète il y a un contrôle total de de
l'information dans le cas de Tik Tok
c'est différent c'est plus comparable à
ce qu'on peut voir sur Facebook sur
Instagram sur Twitter aussi que les
Chinois ont investi à l'image des russes
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant avec des opérations de plus
en plus nombreuses et de plus en plus
sophistiqué
donc un certain nombre de cas pour
illustrer un petit peu le type de
censure que que la Chine pratique sur
TikTok on a des cas de contenu qui ont
disparu de compte qui ont été fermés
parce qu'ils avaient évoqué des points
relatifs à la politique intérieure
chinoise et toujours et notamment et
c'est toujours les mêmes sujets qui
reviennent les événements tiennent à
elle-même
la question tibétaine la question des
Ouigours la question de Taïwan la
question de fallung c'est grosso modo ce
que les Chinois appellent les cinq
poisons donc c'est les cinq menaces les
plus importantes à la pérennité du
régime communiste
et d'une manière générale d'ailleurs il
faut dire je fais une petite parenthèse
mais
les activités informationnelles et de
renseignements chinois apporte d'abord
sur ces questions là parce que
l'obsession de la Chine c'est d'abord la
fin du PCC c'est la pérennité de son
pouvoir
[Musique]
d'une rhétorique anti-démocratique qui
tend à affirmer que la démocratie ne
fonctionne pas que la démocratie
c'est le mensonge en général ils
s'attaque au modèle américain mais pas
uniquement en tout cas il tente
d'affaiblir
l'alternative démocratique en montrant
les défaillances de la démocratie
américaine donc il ne cesse de ressasser
un certain nombre de de cas de racisme
par exemple l'affaire Josh Floyd enfin
voilà ce sont des cas qui sont
régulièrement mis en avant l'hypocrisie
américaine voilà
bien sûr bien sûr
on est dans le dans le schéma de toute
façon des mesures actives donc qui est
un
une pratique soviétique forgée par le
KGB et qui consiste à identifier dans
les sociétés cibles tous les sujets qui
peuvent créer du dissensus qui peuvent
créer des tensions sociales
donc en fait c'est pour ça que
finalement les Russes comme les Chinois
à part sur la question de la démocratie
peut-être ne véhicules pas en matière
d'informationnelle de modèles
particuliers ils essayent juste
d'affaiblir le modèle des autres donc
peu importe ce qu'ils disent finalement
ce qui compte c'est que ça affaiblisse
l'adversaire
on a eu d'autres cas de censure sur Tik
Tok
qui ont été révélés par une enquête du
Washington Post en 2019
et qui montrait comment
finalement les équipes de Tik Tok
étaient amenées à supprimer du contenu
qui était jugé culturellement
problématique
donc là le culturellement est
extrêmement large il faut savoir que
dans la loi sur la sécurité nationale de
2015 la culture a été ajoutée par le PCC
c'est-à-dire que la culture peut être
une menace pour la pérennité du régime
le parti pensant essentiellement au
risque que la démocratie soit importée
en Chine par la diaspora chinoise la
diaspora chinoise vivant dans des
régimes démocratiques des régimes
libéraux en venant en Chine et
susceptible d'importer ses idéaux et
donc de d'affaiblir d'affaiblir le parti
et le parti a
créé si vous voulez un label pour ça
c'est l'infiltration culturelle enfin la
même année le Guardian a révélé a eu
accès à un certain nombre de consignes
qui étaient donnés
de Tik Tok au personnel de Tik Tok et
qui voilà auquel on prescrivait
l'élimination de toute mention d'un
certain nombre de sujets dont ceux que
j'ai déjà mentionné tout à l'heure
notamment tiens amen donc on a un
certain nombre de preuves suffisamment
importantes maintenant qui montre que ce
n'est pas accidentel ce n'est pas
marginal mais qui a une pratique
systématique ou qui tend à ce
systématiser de contrôle des contenus
sur TikTok
autre problème qui est lié à la question
de la censure c'est celui du risque de
manipulation c'est à dire le risque que
Tik Tok soit utilisé comme un vecteur
dans la lutte informatique
internationale chinoise
là on revient à des pratiques qui sont
très similaires à celles qu'on peut
observer sur les réseaux sociaux
occidentaux l'idée est de diffuser voilà
à des représentations alors ça peut être
soit des représentations positives de la
Chine donc mettre en avant ces succès
ça bienveillance le fait qu'appromeux
des relations gagnants gagnants qu'elle
tient compte des particularités du Sud
global comme elle aime elle le rappeler
régulièrement ou diffuser au contraire
des contenus informationnels qui vont
être négatifs donc on revient aux
mesures actives et qui vont essayer
d'affaiblir les sociétés cibles
il y a eu une autre un autre cas
intéressant
qu'on a moins creusé mais où Tik Tok a
été accusé aussi je sais pas à quel
point c'est étayé en tout cas
Tic-Toc a jugé utile de communiquer
publiquement sur ce sur ces questions
Tik Tok a été accusé de supprimer ou en
tout cas d'entraver la création de
compte par des Afro-Américains donc pour
limiter la présence d'Afro-américains
sur en tant que créateur en tant
qu'utilisateur sur sur la plateforme
j'ai pas plus d'informations sur cette
dimension là mais c'est aussi une des
critiques qui a pu être informé à
l'encontre de TikTok alors on en vient à
une question importante quels sont les
données qui sont collectées par Tik Tok
donc j'imagine que c'est une question
que vous avez pu aborder avec
des personnes qui sont plus sur la
dimension technique
j'ai toutefois listé les les données qui
peuvent être collectées par TikTok via
l'utilisation de l'application de
l'application sur sur mobile donc c'est
sans la permission de l'utilisateur son
adresse Courrière son numéro de
téléphone ça date de naissance son
adresse IP bien sûr les contenus du
presse-papier les frappes sur le clavier
lors de l'utilisation de l'application
au moins peut-être même en dehors de
l'application de l'utilisation de
l'application le type d'appareil utilisé
et avec l'autorisation de l'utilisateur
avec plus ou moins de capacités de
contrôle en fonction du modèle de de
mobilité la liste de vos contacts
le micro et la caméra
la bibliothèque de photos la
géolocalisation
et voilà donc ça c'est la liste des des
données dont on sait que Tik Tok est
capable de les collecter et qui donc
sont vraisemblablement ou peuvent être
en tout cas transmises aux parties sur
cette question
puisque c'est une question très sensible
qu'est-ce que TikTok transmet aux
parties il faut en fait la question elle
est très vite
résolue une fois qu'on a compris que
aucune société chinoise ne peut tenir
tête aux parties c'est juste impossible
le système ne le permet pas d'abord
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une loi sur
le renseignement et une loi sur le
contres espionnage
donc de 2014 et de 2017 qui
autorise les services de renseignement
chinois a demandé à toute entreprise
chinoise de transmettre les données dont
elles disposent sur des individus ou des
personnes morales
mais soyons clairs les services de
renseignement chinois le faisaient déjà
avant que ces lois ne soient promulguées
et il ne viendrait à l'esprit d'aucun
entrepreneur chinois qu'il s'agisse
d'une entreprise publique ou privée de
tenir tête au ministère de la Sécurité
d'État donc il faut partir de l'idée que
aucune entreprise
ne peut conserver des données
contre la volonté du du des services de
renseignement chinois qu'il s'agisse du
ministère de Sécurité d'État ou du
ministère de la Sécurité publique
cela étant dit
les données dont on parle sont une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan des données
captées par la Chine ça il faut aussi en
avoir conscience c'est-à-dire que c'est
c'est louable de s'attaquer à la
question des données que Tik Tok peut
collecter mais ça ne représente qu'un
très faible pourcentage de la masse de
données captées par la Chine aujourd'hui
si on parle serait-ce que des États-Unis
qui est l'acteur le plus impliqué dans
cette opposition à TikTok aujourd'hui
les opérations cyber menées contre
l'office du management du personnel
américain ou
l'entreprise Equifax donc qui est une
société de de
régulation des du crédit à la
consommation à offert et on pourrait
ajouter le l'opération de hacking des
données de la chaîne d'hôtel Marriott
avec ces trois opérations cyber la Chine
détient des millions de données sur des
individus américains sur à peu près la
moitié de la population américaine
ce qui est beaucoup plus large et des
données beaucoup plus précises puisque
c'est aussi des données financières
c'est des données sur qui a fait une
demande
de d'habilitation au secret défense aux
États-Unis voilà donc des données
beaucoup plus précieuses pour les
services chinois que celles offerte par
TikTok donc je vais en train de dire
bien sûr que c'est pas important et
qu'il faut pas s'en occuper mais c'est
qu'une toute petite part des données qui
sont captées par par la Chine
aujourd'hui
et qui représente à la fois des données
exploitables dans le cadre d'opération
de renseignements c'est-à-dire que quand
on cible une personne en particulier on
peut récupérer énormément de données sur
sa situation financière sur quel type de
d'habilitation il a demandé
voilà quel est son son portefeuille
éventuellement
ce qu'il a même suivi une thérapie ou
des choses comme ça on peut apprendre
énormément de choses
dans le cadre d'une opération de
renseignement humain donc une personne
qu'on va recruter ensuite pour pour
obtenir des du renseignement ou dans le
cadre de programme de
[Musique]
Big Data et d'intelligence artificielle
donnée qui sont utilisés pour nourrir
ses intelligences artificielles mises en
place par pk
très rapidement pour finir
les autres questions qui se posent
peut-être moins brûlante mais qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est celle du pouvoir du
PDG de Tik Tok qui semble relativement
faible au regard de la société mère by
dance
autre question qui a pu être
évoqué c'est celle du lobbying on
observe depuis le 2019 une
accroissement
très important du budget consacré au
lobbying par TikTok c'est à dire que il
est intéressant de constater enfin il y
a plein d'autres entreprises qui font du
lobbying sans que ce soit forcément
significatif mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que Tik Tok c'est plus attaché à
accroître ses moyens de lobbying puisque
aujourd'hui ils sont bien supérieurs à
ce droit way par exemple
plutôt qu'à répondre aux inquiétudes des
gouvernements ou des utilisateurs quand
elles ont été quand elles se sont
manifestées enfin dernier point que vous
évoquiez également dans dans vos
questions c'est celle d'une éventuelle
volonté de la Chine ou de Tik Tok disons
d'abêtir les sociétés cibles les
populations la jeunesse qui utilise qui
utilisent Tik Tok alors bien évidemment
impossible à vérifier en l'état on n'a
pas assez de données pour voilà il nous
faudrait des études beaucoup plus
poussées
ce qui est certain c'est que
le fonctionnement même de l'algorithme
de Tik Tok fait qu'il y a captation de
l'attention qui est beaucoup plus forte
que dans sur les autres plateformes à
tel point que les autres plateformes
s'en inspirent aujourd'hui
donc cette captation de l'attention fait
que Tik Tok devient plus dangereux
maintenant est-ce que ce que
l'algorithme pousse comme contenu et
orienté par Pékin ou simplement par vos
choix les choix des utilisateurs ça
c'est enfin on l'état on ne sait
toujours pas
bien évidemment on ne peut qu'être
étonné des différences de contenu entre
doing donc la version chinoise et Tik
Tok la version internationale
certains l'ont déjà signalé la version
chinoise comporte du contenu beaucoup
plus éducatif par ailleurs le
gouvernement chinois a limité le temps
d'utilisation de de cette application
pour les pour les citoyens chinois je
crois que c'est 40 minutes par jour
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas chez nous bien
qu'on pourrait réfléchir à ce type de ce
type de contrainte pour ce type ce type
d'acteur donc je m'arrête là pour cette
présentation liminaire et je suis tout à
fait prêt à répondre à vos questions
merci Monsieur on va commencer par les
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup de d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation je ne connaissais pas
votre rapport d'octobre 2021 je m'en
veux d'ailleurs
je l'ai découvert il est
particulièrement éclairant pour tout
dire il fait froid dans le dos
évidemment il ne parle pas que sur Tik
Tok il porte sur la stratégie
d'influence chinoise en général il est
particulièrement éclairant je le
recommande tout nos collègues sénateurs
il est disponible librement sur Internet
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faudrait le
recommander dans toutes les écoles de
sciences politiques école de guerre etc
peut-être d'ailleurs peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il est qu'il est utilisé
alors ma première question elle est dans
d'autres générales il se rapporte et a
été publié il y a un an et demi donc
je voudrais vous demander depuis un an
et demi Tik Tok a évidemment explosé au
niveau de son nombre d'utilisateurs
d'ailleurs vous disiez tout à l'heure
essentiellement des adolescents et des
mais en fait de plus en plus on a
l'impression que c'est un réseau social
qui va prendre la place de beaucoup
d'autres plateformes et qui petit à
petit s'intéresse s'adresse de plus en
plus est utilisé de plus en plus par des
adultes donc par rapport à ce que vous
aviez écrit en octobre 2021 quels sont
pour vous les faits marquants est-ce que
la comment dire les choses se passent
exactement se passe comme avant ou
est-ce que
la croissance du réseau a introduit
d'autres fonctions dans le domaine de
l'influence etc qui n'existait pas
encore ou à développer des une partie
des fonctions la deuxième ordre de
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est qu'il s'agit sont dans les deux
sens je dirais d'un d'un côté il y a
collecte de données de l'autre il y a
production ou poussée de contenu donc
c'est à double sens le premier sens les
collectes de données
vous nous avez expliqué tout à l'heure
et c'était évidemment
clair pour nous que la loi chinoise qui
oblige à déférer à toute demande
sérieusement la loi chinoise qui impose
dans la dans le
comité de direction dans la direction de
Biden d'avoir une cellule du Parti
communiste chinois montre bien qu'il
évidemment aucune
[Musique]
échappatoire aucun échappatoire pour
pour les dirigeants de by dance par
rapport aux parties communistes chinois
mais les dirigeants de Tik Tok
lorsqu'ils sont interrogés aux
États-Unis ou en Europe nous disent nous
ne sommes pas by dance nous sommes des
tonnes nous sommes une société
immatriculer ailleurs d'ailleurs en ce
qui concerne by dance
monde et non pas une d'un signe de ce
lieu est immatriculé aux îles Caïman je
suis pas sûr que dans leur réponse ce
soit quelque chose qui leur confère
beaucoup de
un gros avantage
mais il nous disent
voilà
d'abord nous ne déferrons pas aux
demandes du Parti communiste chinois
deuxièmement jamais de demande de
particulier chinois troisièmement s'il
devait l'avoir demain il ne le ferait
pas en ce qui concerne bidens
c'est même pas la peine de
discuter s'il s'agit d'un mensonge ou
non en ce qui concerne Tik Tok je crois
pour ma part que c'est exactement la
même chose je voudrais vous demander
quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
et sur le
je m'arrête là pour le moment dans
l'autre sens sur la production de
données vous avez écrit dans votre
rapport
les dirigeants de Biden donc là je parle
de désinformation ou de censure les
dirigeants de valides ainsi compris le
PDG tiangle gaming ont déclaré
officiellement qu'ils s'assureraient que
leur produit servirait à promouvoir le
programme de propagande du PCC là il
répondent non pas à nous mais au Parti
communiste chinois ils ont clairement
indiqué que la ligne du parti devait
être intégrée dans les applications de
l'entreprise jusqu'au niveau de
l'algorithme ainsi en 2018 une
application de partage de blague
développée par la compagnie a été
supprimé le produit s'est égaré publié
un contenu qui va à l'encontre des
valeurs fondamentales socialistes à
expliquer
la compagnie a depuis recruté 4000
censeurs supplémentaires et investit
beaucoup d'argent pour développer un
algorithme intégrant ces valeurs
fondamentales socialistes
je voulais vous demander quel est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
un algorithme enfin si vous avez une
idée de ce que veut dire un algorithme
intégrant ces valeurs fondamentales
socialistes et bien évidemment en termes
de production de contenu quels sont les
répercussions
et puis je terminais j'ai d'autres
questions mais je vais laisser parler
mais mes collègues
vous avez parlé presque en terminant
répondu la question sur l'abétisme
[Musique]
sans faire de sans parler de Parti
communiste chinois cette fois-ci mais
c'est il est certain d'ailleurs le
président de la République l'a dit
lui-même que c'était une entreprise
d'une FT confondante un aboutissement
etc donc je pense pas dévoiler grand
chose en disant cela
mais vous avez
dit que pour le savoir exactement pour
pouvoir le déterminer exactement il
faudrait pouvoir comparer le produit en
détail le production de doing est celle
de Tik Tok alors sans sans le le
comparer en détail mais comme vous êtes
une des rares personnes que l'on va
interroger qui parle chinois et que vous
avez sans doute visité l'un et l'autre
on parle de différents évidentes par
exemple celle de de la coupure de
l'appli au bout de 40 minutes pour les
pour les Chinois celle de conduit
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus pédag est-ce que
par une visite par une simple
fréquentation et non pas par la
détermination des algorithmes est-ce que
par une simple visite vous voyez un
certain nombre de caractéristiques très
très
différentes
entre douines et étiquet et l'étiquette
des autres pays
merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors depuis la publication du rapport
on n'a pas noté de transformation
radicale en tout cas de de Tik Tok en
tout cas des opérations
informationnelles chinoises via TiK ToK
on note en revanche
une transformation des opérations
informationnelles d'une manière générale
une évolution de ces opérations qui
globalement suivent la ligne qu'on
appuie identifier dans dans le rapport
avec un durcissement croissant de ces
opérations c'est à dire que la dimension
coercitive agressive de ces opérations
de plus en plus manifeste
ces opérations sont également de plus en
plus sophistiqués
sophistiqué ça veut dire que
auparavant
quand on identifié on tombait sur une
voilà du contenu manipulé contenu
informationnel manipulé c'était il nous
fallait à peine quelques minutes pour
identifier que c'était du contenu
manipulé et pour remonter jusqu'à un
opérateur chinois un acteur chinois ça
devient de plus en plus difficile en
tout cas ça nous demande de plus en plus
de temps c'est plus fin il y a plus
d'intermédiaires de plus en plus
d'acteurs qui ne sont pas des acteurs
qui appartiennent à l'appareil du parti
état donc ça peut être des acteurs
chinois mais qui n'apparaît qui
n'appartiennent pas à cet appareil du
parti état donc c'est déjà un peu plus
difficile
de remonter et puis il y a des acteurs
qui sont des des non chinois donc des
acteurs locaux des sociétés ciblées
alors c'est très fort par exemple sur
Youtube ça on le voit très bien
d'évoluer sur Youtube où il y a des
comptes alors soit des comptes créés
par les Chinois eux-mêmes et de manière
plus subtile des comptes qui existent
déjà qui fonctionne bien qui sont popul
Aires et que les Chinois vont tenter
d'acheter qui vont payer vont payer les
producteurs les amis et les créateurs de
contenu pour qu'il diffuse du contenu
favorable à la Chine ou défavorable à
leur cible
donc ça c'est ça c'est une évolution
très nette et très rapide
ils apprennent vite
après bien sûr les Chinois n'ont pas
tout à fait la même stratégie que les
Russes il sont beaucoup inspirés des
Russes mais leur stratégie reste en
partie différentes les Russes mises en
beaucoup plus sur le qualitatif
d'une manière générale leurs opérations
beaucoup plus subtiles pas toujours mais
en moyenne disons
les Chinois mise en plus sur la quantité
par exemple depuis à peu près 2-3 ans
les contenus rediffusés
les contenus produits par qnon aux
États-Unis et rediffuser sur les réseaux
sociaux le sont plus souvent par la
Chine que par la Russie c'était pas le
cas par exemple
il y a quatre ou cinq ans aujourd'hui
les chinois sont plus actifs que les
Russes en matière de diffusion des
théories du complot information
manipulées etc par les réseaux qui
annoncent aux États-Unis donc il y a une
stratégie qui est quand même basée sur
sur le quantitatif quitte à
diffuser des produits beaucoup moins
sophistiqués parce que il s'appuie aussi
sur un certain nombre de d'avancées des
sciences cognitives par exemple on sait
aujourd'hui que plus on est exposé une
information même si c'est une
information fausse plus le cerveau a
tendance à croire à cette information
donc c'est pas tant la enfin c'est pas
seulement la qualité de l'information
qualité de son de la manipulation de
l'information si vous voulez mais tout
simplement le degré auquel vous êtes
exposé à cette information
donc donc ça les Chinois en tiennent
compte dans leur dans leur
opérations informationnelles de la même
manière bien évidemment il y a c'est
c'est ces opérations informationnelles
font sens entre elles elles sont liées
entre elles et donc on renvoie de l'une
à l'autre par exemple dans le rapport on
a évoqué la question de
l'opération qu'on a appelé infection 2.0
donc autour de du covid 19 et la volonté
des Chinois de faire croire que les
États-Unis a fait fabriqué le virus du
Sark of 2 ils ont ciblé dans cette
opération une base qui est la base de
Ford dietrique aux États-Unis et c'est
la base qui avait déjà été ciblée par le
KGB en 1983 dans le cas de l'opération
infection et donc cette base avait été
accusée d'avoir fabriqué le virus du
sida pour décimer les populations
afro-américaines et gay aux États-Unis
le fait que les Chinois utilisent un
certain nombre de référents qui sont des
référents puissants
des théories du complot montre que la
sophistication n'est pas toujours utile
puisque en mettant quelques mots clés
quelques quelques référents clés et bien
on n'a pas besoin de plus de
sophistication que ça ça suffit à faire
sens et à renvoyer à un imaginaire
puissant du complot
en l'occurrence américain donc pas de
changement majeur ou en tout cas pas de
changement spécifique à Tik Tok mais
d'une manière générale une
sophistication croissante une
des opérations qui sont de plus en plus
du coup clandestine avec de plus en plus
d'intermédiaires y compris locaux et
donc pour l'instant le problème on est
pénalisé par l'absence de travaux en
profondeur sur TikTok donc il faudrait
ça va venir parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent maintenant sur les
opérations d'influence chinoise et donc
on aura vraisemblablement bientôt des
études fines sur voilà le nombre de
fauconstes ce qu'il diffuse exactement
etc ça viendra sans doute assez assez
rapidement
sur la question du collecte et contenu
alors une petite précision les cellules
du parti il y en a dans toutes les
entreprises c'est pas propre à Tik Tok
cela étant dit
le degré d'indépendance est plus ou
moins important c'est-à-dire que pendant
très longtemps il y a tout un tas
d'entreprises qui ont été assez
tranquilles à partir du moment où elle
donne l'impression de respecter les
grandes lignes fixées par le Parti
communiste dans l'application elles sont
relativement indépendantes et le les
membres du comité enfin de la cellule du
parti dans les entreprises ne va pas
toujours vérifier dans le détail ce qui
se passe voilà
mais le contrôle croissant depuis deux
ans à peu près sur les entreprises du
secteur des nouvelles technologies fait
que c'est de plus en plus difficile pour
ces entreprises d'avoir vraiment une
pratique commerciale qui soit totalement
indépendante du contrôle du parti
oui Tik Tok a dit qu'il n'avait jamais
obéi à une demande de ce type voilà de
transmettre des informations sur les
utilisateurs à l'étranger c'est faux
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure ou en tout
cas peut-être qu'ils n'ont jamais
transmis d'informations mais ils ont
autorisé l'accès à leurs informations
aux personnel de by dance qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais on joue
sur les mots puisque la conclusion le
résultat est identique c'est la
possibilité pour Biden c'est d'avoir
accès aux informations des utilisateurs
non basés enfin des utilisateurs de Tik
Tok
sur le sur le contenu bien évidemment
oui qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des
valeurs socialistes qu'une application
soit à l'image voilà au caractéristiques
chinoises voilà c'est très clair en fait
c'est la nécessité pour toutes ces
entreprises de se conformer à
l'idéologie du parti aux grandes lignes
fixées par le parti lignes qui sont de
plus en plus sévères de plus en plus
strictes
et qui impose d'autres entreprises
de diffuser du contenu qui se conforme à
la fois à l'idéologie sur un plan
politique mais aussi sur le plan des
mœurs donc voilà pas de contenu à
connotation sexuelle
pas de contenu irrespectueux vis-à-vis
de certaines parties de la population
voilà dire que les contrôles sont
beaucoup plus forts que ce que nous nous
imposons
à nos plateformes ou y compris au
plateformes type Tik Tok
[Musique]
donc voilà ça répond en partie aussi sur
les caractéristiques du contenu
je crois que là la Chine voilà elle a
intérêt enfin en tout cas
sur Tik Tok à l'intérêt à diffuser du
contenu qui va à la fois et c'est ça qui
est qui différencie aussi bien que ce
qu'il faut prendre faudrait peut-être
nuancer un petit peu mais en tout cas de
manière un peu superficielle ce qui
différencie la Chine et la Russie c'est
que alors que la Russie tend à diffuser
plutôt du contenu qui est d'une qui est
la plupart du temps négatif donc il
cible des faiblesses de la société viser
et les montants épingles les diffuses
très largement etc
il suffit de voir ce que fait Wagner par
exemple sur sur l'influence française en
Afrique et on en a une idée assez claire
même si les spécialistes de la Russie
montrent que depuis quelques temps et
peut-être d'ailleurs influencé par la
Chine les Russes recommencent à
s'intéresser à la diffusion d'une image
positive de la Russie donc c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il faudrait un petit peu
nuancer en tout cas la Chine elle essaye
de tenir toujours les deux bouts avec du
diffusion de contenu positif sur
elle-même
sur sa politique sur son respect
des pays en voie de développement du Sud
global etc
sur sa puissance technologique
industrielle sportive ce que vous voulez
et à la fois du contenu négatif à
l'image des Russes du coup pour diviser
les sociétés ciblées pour voilà créer du
dissensus etc
sur les différences oui
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
oui il y a des différences manifestes
sont celles que vous avez mentionnées
donc des contenus beaucoup plus qui sont
expliqués parce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire c'est c'est politique aussi
lié au bonheur en Chine qui impose voilà
et et le contrôle sur les pratiques
addictives donc là le site inping a
imposé un contrôle des réductions des
pratiques addictives c'est pour ça que
aussi les pratiques de jeux vidéo ont
été profondément réduites
limité que les cybercafé ou avant
envoyer des des adolescents passer leur
journée leur nuit sont beaucoup plus
contrôlés
donc c'est c'est en partie pour ça
ce que l'on ne sait pas c'est à quel
point le fait de pousser du contenu qui
tend à abêtir les utilisateurs est une
stratégie de la Chine ou pas
c'est-à-dire est-ce que c'est une
conséquence de la néfaste de
l'algorithme seulement
parce que a priori on est en classe à
penser que l'algorithme il a été surtout
conçu pour
pour faire du profit c'est ça l'intérêt
de de la société de Tik Tok avant tout
et de bindance pas pour diffuser des
fausses informations etc maintenant la
plateforme ayant du succès elle
intéresse forcément les services chinois
qui eux peuvent être tentés de diffuser
du contenu via cette plateforme à quel
point c'est fait en accord en
coopération avec Tik Tok c'est difficile
de savoir
j'ai une ou deux questions à vous poser
mais j'en profite pour dire à mes
collègues qui se signalent s'il y a des
prises de parole où il y a eu tout le
monde très bien c'est noté
je me fais un peu l'avocat du diable
mais pour vous amener à
préciser le les choses vous avez
commencé par dire que finalement les
données qui étaient collectées sont en
tout cas la nature des données n'était
pas pire que sur d'autres plateformes et
même dit qu'il y a peut-être qu'ils ont
collecté un peu moins que Facebook
enfin que meta vous avez évoqué aussi
vous avez fait un distinguo entre les
données qui sont collectées sans
autorisation en faisant non date de
naissance bon
un scoop on s'en doute plus les uns les
autres je n'avais pas de compte Tik Tok
j'en ai toujours pas mais je suis quand
même allé voir ce que c'était
quand on s'inscrit on est bien obligé de
donner sa date de naissance etc donc il
y a rien de pas tant dans vous pouvez
mentir
oui enfin non jamais moi je suis pas
contre
personne il y a personne viendra
contrôler ça derrière mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on peut bien se
douter quand on s'inscrit dans toute
bonne foi que tout ça est connecté et ce
qu'on fait sur l'ensemble des
plateformes donc le problème c'est pas
ce qu'on met à disposition c'est
l'utilisation qui peut en effet mais
est-ce que vous pourriez nous nous
repréciser de votre point de vue du
point de vue de quelqu'un qui connaît la
culture chinoise ce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans votre audition
finalement de dire que un état fait
attention pour le dire gentiment au
contenu qui sont disponibles et ce qu'on
accepte de fournir à la population c'est
repas de pas de données pornographiques
bon bah enfin en France non plus
normalement sur une heure de grande
écoute sur des chaînes de télévision
contre les par la com il y a pas de
contenu pandographique donc sans vouloir
faire de relativisme ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser finalement entre
meta ou Tik Tok dans les pays respectifs
où c'est diffusé est-ce que finalement
ça n'est pas simplement lié à la culture
locale encore une fois sans faire de
relativisme et qu'il y a des choses
qu'on n'a pas envie de laisser la vue de
d'enfants ou de gens qui j'ai dit que je
me faisais l'avocat du diable mais oui
bien sûr est-ce qu'il y a une différence
profonde ou quelle est la nature de
cette différence puisqu'il y en a une
entre les problèmes qu'on rencontre avec
par exemple Cambridge Analytica
ou ce qu'on peut supposer ce qui sera
fait par les tâches chinois des données
TikTok ou encore sur le fait que d'un
côté on a un contrôle qui est
probablement après qu'on a vu ce que
l'algorithme pouvait donner on a un
contrôle sur ce qu'on a envie de de
comment dire de voir mis à disposition
et d'un autre côté des plateformes qui
au contraire par souhait par souci du
profit laisse filer ils peuvent créer
des difficultés parce que c'est presque
le problème inverse avec facebook donc
là je me disais je me fais l'avocat du
diable mais c'est que pour vous puissiez
nous exposer ça en nous expliquant
pourquoi ça peut fonctionner dans la
culture chinoise
et la question additionnelle c'est cette
façon de de
comment dire de contrôler les contenus
est-ce que c'est tenable à long terme
parce que la question de l'addiction de
l'algorithme sur la réaction neuronale
et ce que les neurosciences nous
apprennent depuis quelques années ce qui
a une différence de fond entre un entre
un chinois et un Occidental une fois que
l'algorithme est bien fichu et qu'on est
dessus ce que la limitation à 40 minutes
est-ce que la limitation des jeux vidéo
en ligne c'est tenable à long terme pour
le pouvoir chinois
est-ce qu'au bout d'un moment ceux qui
pensent pouvoir infinie et faire une
utilisation avec un profit étatique ou
politique finissent pas par se prendre
les pieds dans le tapis
est-ce que vous pourriez préciser ce que
vous entendez par culture du coup est-ce
que vous voulez dire est-ce que ça
marche parce que la culture chinoise
fait que l'utilisation on est plus
vertueuse
je crois pas
c'est plutôt le contrôle c'est à dire
que c'est un certain nombre de
prescriptions du parti qui font que
la
l'orientation de la plateforme
a pris une toute autre direction que que
chez nous si on avait le même type de de
critères imposé nos plateformes sans
doute que l'orientation serait peut-être
similaire à celle de Deauville
en revanche si je reprends la question
sur
finalement
si collecte pas enfin pas plus de
données que facebook du coup il y a la
question de
d'affaires comme ça de Cambridge United
par exemple
oui donc bien évidemment alors d'après
certaines études du coup meta Facebook
collecte plus de données dans certains
cas ces données peuvent être utilisées
contre nos intérêts c'est bien évident
mais ce qui fait la différence majeure
c'est que mais elle n'est que là on est
là c'est la nature des régimes
politiques et du coup la nature des
régimes politiques fait que
l'utilisation de des données peut être
très différente en Chine
et aux Etats-Unis même si aux États-Unis
peuvent être utilisés contre nos
intérêts essentiellement économiques
mais parfois même un peu imaginer
politique dans lequel la Chine c'est
très manifeste et c'est beaucoup plus
fort
par ailleurs il y a peut-être une
différence qu'il faut mentionner aussi
c'est la question de la quand on
réfléchit finalement à ce que font les
Chinois on peut toujours se poser de la
question de la réciprocité dire pourquoi
Twitter n'est pas autorisé alors bon
nous on n'a pas de plateforme de ce type
en France on ni même en Europe mais mais
en tout cas c'est la question que les
Américains devraient poser c'est à dire
pourquoi on devrait tolérer TikTok si
vous vous ne tolérez pas Twitter
Facebook etc en Chine nous on est prêt à
le faire mais faites la même chose et on
pourrait
étendre la comparaison à tout un tas
d'autres tout un tas d'autres questions
y compris la présence et le travail des
journalistes dire les médias chinois
travaillent de manière totalement libre
en France
pourquoi c'est si compliqué pour nos
journalistes qui sont parfois harcelés
parfois on subisse des refus de visa
peuvent être embêtés par la police sur
place
voilà
parfois ça va beaucoup plus loin peuvent
être aussi poursuivis devant la justice
les chercheurs aussi d'ailleurs il y a
une chercheur française qui a poursuivi
par Huawei
oui insulter voilà donc
à chaque fois je pense ce qu'il faut
remettre en avant avec des limites parce
que nous vivons dans un régime
démocratique et bien sûr on va pas
adopter les mêmes pratiques que qu'un
régime autoritaire mais on peut leur
renvoyer le fait que
en tolère des choses qu'il ne tolère pas
et peut-être là il y a matière à
négocier et disons en tout cas les
alerter sur sur ce genre de de
d'asymétrie d'une manière générale la
Chine on est souvent dans des relations
asymétriques ce qui fait qu'on aurait
intérêt à négocier le plus largement
possible quel que soit le sujet même si
je parlais essentiellement de questions
politiques
on aurait intérêt à négocier le plus
souvent possible elle est à l'échelon
européen et pas par l'échelon national
pour pour peser plus lourd
est-ce que la limite est tenable
c'est une question quelle est
extrêmement difficile de répondre
il y a quelques
temps
une vingtaine d'années les Chinois
avaient introduit des élections au
niveau local et au niveau du village et
on se demandait si c'était pas le vert
dans le fruit que finalement par un
processus de c'était des vrais élections
donc tout le monde pouvait se présenter
alors il y avait qu'un parti autorisé
c'est le parti communiste mais on
pouvait être candidat hors partie
et est-ce que ça allait pas entraîner un
processus de politisation voilà des
ruraux et puis par par contamination
capillarité ça allait remonter la chaîne
la chaîne de de étatique bon finalement
pour l'instant en tout cas il y a eu
rien de tel c'est resté globalement ce
contrôle ça a même profité aux parties
en un sens pendant un moment puisque ça
a renforcé sa légitimité
donc on peut se demander voilà donc
c'est tout à fait possible que le parti
arrive ce qui caractérise le Parti
communiste chinois c'est quand même ça
très grande ductilité c'est une capacité
à s'adapter quand même aux situations
alors plus ou moins bien sûr mais
la Chine c'est pas forcément un régime
dans lequel
toutes
expression d'un mécontentement et et
réprimer il y a les manifestations qu'on
a vu il y a quelques semaines
liés aux règles de contrôle
de la pandémie
c'est alors même si elle était d'une
ampleur un peu nouvelle ce type de
manifestation de de de contestation même
de manifestations qui voilà de les gens
vont manifester dans la rue sans même
s'ils disent pas exactement pourquoi
c'est pas très clair ou qui vise qu'ils
accusent les cadres locaux pour
permettre en cause l'hégémonie du que
c'est etc les citoyens chinois savent
très bien faire ça
c'est tolérer en partie c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une quand même une dose de
contestation de à la marge qui est qui
est tolérée
tout ça pour dire que le parti est
beaucoup plus subtil que il peut donner
l'impression parfois et donc il est
peut-être capable de
réussir à tenir les choses avec avec
cette application mais
ce qu'on note aussi depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de steamping c'est une
rigidification du système c'est à dire
que cette ductilité elle était vraiment
caractéristique du des dirigeants
précédents surtout routine Town et même
giant un petit peu et steamping a eu
tendance à casser un petit peu ces
mécanismes d'ingénierie du consentement
si vous voulez et aujourd'hui
la répression est beaucoup plus forte le
contrôle est beaucoup plus fort
l'idéologie est revenue
a pris une place plus importante même si
c'est beaucoup un jeu c'est un
maquillage c'est de la rhétorique mais
elle est là malgré tout et cette
rigidification fait que le système est
sans doute en même temps plus fragile
c'est-à-dire que vous avez plus de
chance d'être réprimé pour des activités
jugées
hostile au PCC mais en même temps il me
semble que le PCC est beaucoup moins
capable de serrer beaucoup moins capable
de résister à un mouvement de
contestation d'ampleur aujourd'hui en
Chine que peut-être sous routine tard
d'abord parce qu'il a cassé un certain
nombre de mécanismes voilà de de
consentement du de la population et
aussi parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
aveugle sur ce qui se passe au niveau
local c'est-à-dire que il y a un certain
nombre de mécanismes qui permettaient la
remontée d'informations jusqu'au sommet
du pouvoir qui ont été cassés société et
on a affaire à un pouvoir qui est très
largement mal informé et qui ne perçoit
peut-être pas complètement ce qui se
passe
sur le terrain
un moment de saillie
merci beaucoup quelques questions et
peut-être de demande plutôt de de
précision vous avez évoqué la censure le
retrait de certains contenus ayant très
à des sujets bien précis vous avez
évoqué aussi l'injonction faite aux
entrepreneurs de donner remonter les
données de leurs entreprises ou de leur
leurs clients
pouvez-vous nous dire très précisément
quel est le cadre législatif chinois à
cet endroit y a-t-il un cadre législatif
qui a été énoncé
y a-t-il une différence entre cette
injonction faite aux entrepreneurs
chinois et ce qui se passe avec les
plateformes américaines sur requête de
l'État fédéral et DSi des entreprises
qui traitent de la donnée y compris or
États-Unis doivent fournir les données
utilisées donc par les les abonnés une
autre question porte sur les comptes
y a-t-il aussi à travers les amis les
utilisateurs c'est à ceux qui ne
seraient pas abonnés à TikTok la
reconstitution ce qu'on appelle des
Shadow profils pour se doter davantage
d'informations sur la société
occidentale en général est-ce que ce
sont les pratiques aussi avérées à votre
connaissance vous êtes un spécialiste de
la stratégie d'influence pouvez-vous
nous dire aussi si les plateformes
américaines je pense notamment à
Facebook pourrait faire l'objet d'un
gérance de la part de la Chine à la star
de ce qui s'est passé dans la fameuse
affaire Cambridge a été capté savoir les
Russes ont pu s'infiltrer et manipuler
les opinions à la faveur de scrutin
électoraux est-ce qu'une telle stratégie
est à l'oeuvre de ce que vous connaissez
exploitant les les failles de ces
plateformes
américaines et puis j'avais une dernière
question je sais pas ce que c'est un
algorithme addictif j'ai l'impression
que c'est plutôt les contenus qui sont
addictifs ou est-ce que vous pourriez
préciser
je suis pas une informaticienne j'ai pas
une spécialiste des algorithmes
mais c'est quoi un algorithme addictif
que somme toute les les l'Instagram
Facebook ça c'est aussi très addictif en
réalité qu'est-ce qui va différencier
l'algorithme
merci bien alors sur le cadre législatif
c'est ce que j'ai mentionné au début de
mon intervention c'est à dire qu'il y a
un certain nombre de lois qui ont été
votées par
par la Chine par l'assemblée qui
exige ou en tout cas qui impose à tout
individu ou personne moral te
transmettre les informations au service
de renseignement chinois qui pourraient
le demander mais encore une fois c'est
je pense que ça n'a pas d'importance
puisque de toute façon ils étaient
capables de le faire avant
donc bien évidemment et on peut on peut
essayer de comparer le cadre législatif
en Chine et aux États-Unis
il y a de toute façon des différences
majeures c'est que en Chine si non
seulement vous vous prendrez pas le
risque de dire non aux agents de vos
officiers de ministères de la Sécurité
d'État qui vient de vous demander des
informations sur vos utilisateurs et
et si vous n'êtes pas content du
traitement vous n'irez pas en justice
parce que parce que d'abord vous perdrez
et puis parce que les les conséquences y
compris pour votre intégrité physique
pour être catastrophique ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas aux
États-Unis donc enfin je veux dire c'est
les deux mécanismes les deux systèmes
sont tout simplement incomparables ça
veut pas dire que le gouvernement
américain a pas accès à un certain
nombre de données etc bien évidemment il
faut pas être
angélique mais mais on parle de système
qui sont complètement différents et dans
le cas du système américain vous avez
toujours la possibilité de d'aller en
justice et compris pour dire que vous
avez été
traité de manière illégale par par le
gouvernement américain
sur la l'infiltration
alors oui les Chinois utilisent créer
des comptes alors sur Tik Tok à quel
point on sait pas c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que on n'a
pas de de recherche
qui a été menée sur Tik Tok suffisamment
fine pour qu'on ait une idée précise à
la fois des des maudits operandis et
voilà de la quantité de faux compte
manipulée par des chinois sur Tik Tok
mais il y en a vraisemblablement
après est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de créer
des faux comptes sur TikTok pour
récolter du de ces informations j'en
suis pas persuadé en fait je pense que
les données sont recueillies je ne vous
ai posé pas la question de création de
faux compte d'accord je vous posez la
question de rec
onstit de profil de nos abonnés à TikTok
c'est à dire l'entourage d'une famille
les amis d'une famille le réseau d'une
free comme facebook le fait oui oui
probablement probablement
ils le font probablement comme ils le
font sur les autres plateformes
dans tous les cas
les plateformes sont utilisées à la fois
voilà pour diffuser du contenu et pour
collecter des informations qu'il
s'agisse d'informations
sur des individus ou globalement sur des
segments de société ou sur des sociétés
entières
ça c'est évident même si on n'a pas
d'enquête précise qui permettrait de de
le chiffrer ou de détailler le le module
operandi
et alors qu'est-ce qu'un algorithme
addictif mais la question aussi de la
gérance dans les plateformes étrangères
à la star de ce qu'on fait les rues
alors vous voulez dire au sein des
sociétés au sein de la société ou au
sein du réseau je vais répéter ma
question des plateformes comme facebook
on fait l'objet d'un gérance étrangère
on a évoqué l'affaire Cambri génétique à
clairement les failles par le réseau
social lui-même ont permis russe voilà
de manière avérée de s'infiltrer de
manipuler des scrutins électoraux etc
est-ce que les chinois ont la même
stratégie alors ils l'ont peut-être mais
pour l'instant on n'a pas de cas
on n'a pas on n'a pas de cas qui serait
similaire à celui de Cambridge Analytica
pour les chinois mais on sait que les
Chinois s'intéressent à l'ingérence
électorale
comme ça ils le font déjà donc ensuite
il n'y a qu'un pas à franchir pour
exploiter ce type d'outils aussi dans le
cadre d'un Gerra sol d'ingérence
électorale ils le font de manière fin
depuis longtemps et avec vigueur à
Taïwan
de plus en plus au Canada en Australie
en Nouvelle-Zélande
voilà il commence à s'y intéresser aussi
aux États-Unis
et
l'Europe viendra l'Europe viendra donc
il faut il faut voir je pense que il
faut il faut vraiment voir ce qui se
passe d'abord à Taïwan ensuite en
Australie par exemple en
Nouvelle-Zélande au Canada comme un
petit peu l'image de notre avenir
même si bien évidemment
la nature des régimes politiques des
systèmes politiques des du des modes de
scrutin etc à fond que
est un unitaire état fédéraux etc
forcément les stratégies sont
différentes mais la volonté de peser sur
les élections et est évidente
et donc sur l'algorithme addictif
alors là encore une fois c'est pas ma
spécialité mais ce que semble dire les
les techniciens les ingénieurs c'est que
Tik Tok et la plateforme la plus
efficace pour créer de l'addiction parce
que l'algorithme est mieux capable
disons de comprendre ce qui vous
intéresse il suffit que vous passiez un
tout petit peu plus longtemps sur une
mini vidéo alors et ça se joue en
microseconde
c'est rien du tout si l'algorithme
détecte que vous avez été un tout petit
peu plus
long à passer une vidéo que la
précédente c'est qu'il y a au moins un
intérêt et donc elle va pousser du
contenu qui ressemble à celui-ci c'est
ça cette qualité du du de l'algorithme
qui lui permet d'être aussi addictif
bien plus efficace que ce que YouTube ou
Instagram sont capables de faire
quand ils essayent d'évaluer les
algorithmes évaluent vos goûts
merci monsieur le Président merci à vous
pour déjà toutes ces réponses quelques
questions simples en plus de toutes
celles qui viennent de vous être posées
vous avez
identifié la volonté TikTok d'affaiblir
des sociétés cibles il a surtout été
question des Américains est-ce qu'on a
connaissance finalement d'attaque sur
des sociétés une hiérarchie de ces
sociétés ciblées par Tik Tok donc c'est
la première question la deuxième
question
Tik Tok un public assez jeune est-ce que
ce n'est pas contradictoire par rapport
finalement à la volonté de collecter un
certain nombre de données j'imagine que
ces données sur un public différent
d'entreprise de décideurs les données
seraient peut-être plus intéressantes
donc comment expliquer vous ces menaces
qu'on ressent par rapport à ce réseau et
là et finalement le public jeune qui est
visé la troisième une question concerne
ce réseau qui est en fait le seul réseau
social qui a réussi à séduire aussi bien
l'Asie l'Amérique que l'Europe et
comment vous expliquer finalement que ce
soit le seul réseau social qui a réussi
à s'implanter dans tous les pays du
monde alors que d'autres réseaux sociaux
ont bien tenté de le faire donc quels
sont les raisons de ce succès à
l'international et dernière question
dans votre rapport vous indiquez que la
direction de Tik Tok recevait
quotidiennement des directives de
modération
de la part des autorités chinoises donc
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
ces directives est-ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de ces directives
nombreuses quelles sont leurs contenus
leur fréquence là j'ai dit
quotidiennement mais
ça représente quoi en masse je vous
remercie
alors quand je parlais des sociétés
ciblées c'était pas par Tik Tok mais par
la Chine enfin par le Parti communiste
chinois
donc est-ce que ça rejaillit sur Tik Tok
difficile de le savoir c'est c'est
toujours pareil tout dépend à quel point
Tik Tok et contrôlé par le PCC donc je
pense qu'il faut là être prudent
je pense que les ce qui est plus
inquiétant en fait c'est d'une part les
données qui sont collectées qui peuvent
être utilisées par des acteurs
étatique ou appartenant aux parties
chinois c'est une chose la deuxième
c'est du contenu qui peut être poussé
par des acteurs malveillants disons
qui sont forcément liés à Tik Tok donc
je pense que le succès de Tik Tok est
plutôt une opportunité saisie par les
acteurs de la lutte informationnelle
chinois plutôt que une vaste stratégie
mise en place par Pékin et dans la
création de TikTok etc donc
ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est le fonctionnement est probablement
assez similaire à celui des mesures
actives du KGB pendant la guerre froide
c'est à dire que vous avez des
membres des services de renseignement
des organes qui font de la
désinformation type département de la
propagande par exemple chinoise et qui
identifie des sujets qui peuvent
affaiblir les sociétés cibles donc
on va on va parler des gilets jaunes
quand il y a une manifestations en
France on va parler du mariage gay au
Canada parce que on sent que ça peut
être un sujet qui va diviser la
population ou en tout cas divisé par
exemple la diaspora chinoise et le reste
de la société la diaspora chinoise qui
est souvent un peu plus conservatrice
sur ce genre de de sujet donc voilà
c'est ça qui vont faire donc il y a des
si vous voulez des des membres de ces
administrations de ces agences qui sont
responsables d'identifier les sujets qui
peuvent être exploités et ensuite on
imagine par quelle stratégie on va
exploiter les sujets en question et Tik
Tok et un des vecteurs que ces acteurs
peuvent utiliser et souvent ne se limite
pas à un vecteur c'est à dire que Tik
Tok c'est l'un des vecteurs qui va être
utilisé dans une vaste stratégie
multi multicano en fait donc on va à la
fois faire du TikTok du Twitter du
Facebook du média traditionnel
des réseaux enfin du humain par des
associations professionnelles des
associations sportives des associations
d'amitié on peut utiliser des fines
tanks des des
maisons d'édition etc et c'est
l'ensemble de ces vecteurs qui vont être
utilisés pour diffuser un message une
représentation etc donc il faut pas
isoler TikTok de l'ensemble du du
répertoire d'action dont dispose le
parti ce qui veut pas dire non plus que
tout est parfaitement coordonné et que
les acteurs n'agissent pas forcément
toujours en très très bonne entente
certains étant même en compétition les
uns avec les autres donc c'est pas
toujours très bien coordonné mais en
tout cas les grandes lignes
sont les mêmes
et sur la question de la hiérarchie bien
évidemment il y a il y a des sociétés
qui sont ciblées en priorité
soit parce que
pour différentes raisons c'est à dire
que certaines sociétés sont
intéressantes parce que elles s'opposent
ou en tout cas elles sont perçues comme
des adversaires ou des opposants aux
parties
typiquement les États-Unis ouais ou des
rivaux disons
à la Chine ça peut être aussi parce
qu'elles sont déjà jugées comme fragiles
et donc on va les fragiliser un peu plus
ça peut être parce que dans tel pays en
particulier la Chine a des intérêts
qu'elle veut défendre donc elle veut
accroître
ou en raison de la présence de diaspora
d'une diaspora importante le fait que la
France par exemple et la plus grande
diaspora chinoise d'Europe fait qu'elle
est ciblée en particulier aussi sur ce
segment là
mais moins que l'Australie ou le Canada
qui ont des communautés encore plus
importantes et qui en plus
subissent
le fait d'être des états fédéraux qui
sont plus faciles à pénétrer pour les
Chinois puisqu'il c'est plus facile de
pénétrer les autorités locales que de
participer à des élections nationales ou
tout de suite les élus sont plus
visibles etc donc c'est les sociétés qui
sont plus facilement
pénétrables
donc sur les publics jeunes
donc c'est pas des nuées d'intérêt et ça
rejoint la réponse que je viens de faire
c'est à dire que le public jeune c'est
pas il est pas isolé du reste
c'est-à-dire que Tik Tok est privilégié
pour toucher la jeunesse mais les autres
segments de la population peuvent être
touchés par d'autres
moyens par d'autres canaux de la même
manière que quand on veut toucher la
diaspora en priorité bah on va utiliser
wechat parce que c'est ce qui fonctionne
le mieux ou ou d'autres médias voilà par
exemple les si on regarde les médias
traditionnels
vous avez c'est difficile à chiffrer
avec précision mais ils ont grosso modo
95% des médias en langue chinoise hors
de Chine sont contrôlés par le parti
si vous prenez la France vous n'avez
aucun média papier en chinois
indépendant du parti nouvelle d'Europe
est un média complètement contrôlé par
le PCC et c'est ça qui informe notre
communauté d'origine enfin les Français
d'origine chinoise qui s'informent
beaucoup alors moins les à partir de la
troisième génération c'est moi le cas
peut-être mais à ce moment là c'est
souvent
wechat qui prend le relais mais ça c'est
un vrai problème dont on parle peu bien
sûr il y a RFI qui fait un travail
formidable mais avec trop peu de moyens
et donc on laisse un segment de notre
population
être informé par la Chine y compris avec
des opérations d'appel à la à aller aux
urnes alors sans directif de vote pour
l'instant mais je pense qu'il teste il
teste les pour voir à quel point ils
sont capables de mobiliser la population
quand il s'agit de les faire voter
donc tout ça et tout ça est très
inquiétant et Tik Tok c'est qu'un
segment voilà c'est un outil qui permet
de toucher un segment particulier en
gardant l'esprit que ce segment même si
effectivement c'est des adolescents
essentiellement qui n'ont pas encore
d'activité professionnelle ils en auront
un jour donc ils auront pu être
influencé par des contenus
ils ont pu du coup avoir ils pourront
peut-être avoir une image plus positive
de la Chine que les générations
précédentes et donc c'est aussi des
stratégies de long terme
et enfin
vous aviez une question sur la dimension
mondiale oui pourquoi ça se diffuse
voilà je pense que la réponse c'est
aussi la qualité de l'algorithme qui
permet de répondre à chaque fois en
s'adaptant aux
besoins et au goût des populations
locales
ah oui alors on n'a pas on n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations pour ça il y a
eu quelques fuites et donc on sait que
ça existe que ça existe ce qui n'est pas
étonnant puisque tous les médias chinois
reçoivent des des directives elles
prennent la forme souvent de liste de
mots interdits et de liste de mots ou de
sujets à promouvoir en priorité
en général ça prend cette forme là il y
a un site Internet notamment américain
qui est associé à la à l'Université
Harvard je crois et qui diffuse
régulièrement ce type de directive du
département de la propagande quand il y
a des fuites il y en a régulièrement en
fait
monsieur gatelin
oui merci monsieur le Président du côté
tout ça est très intéressant je diverge
un peu avec vous sur les
volontés d'influence électorale de la
Chine on aura peut-être l'occasion un
jour d'en discuter je crois qu'il y a
une autre stratégie mais je voulais
revenir un peu sur une question de fond
c'est en gros de quoi Tik Tok et le nom
parce que
l'objectif très clairement affiché et
très tôt c'est de devenir le premier
média jeune le premier média adolescent
dans le monde ça l'est aujourd'hui avec
plus d'un milliard d'utilisateurs
la deuxième question est de savoir
est-ce que c'est une entreprise
commerciale pas tellement on voit bien
qu'il y a des ressorts idéologiques
derrière et puis que tout ça est abrité
par le le pouvoir du régime de Pékin
mais quand on regarde le peu
d'informations qu'on a sur les recettes
publicitaires c'est pas très glorieux
c'est beaucoup plus puissant que
snapchat et ça fait pas le quart de ces
recettes publicitaires
et il y a une annonce qui a été faite
par les dirigeants de Tik Tok disant
qu'ils allaient consacrer la moitié de
leur recette publicitaire rétribué les
créateurs donc je me dis on est dans
quelque chose d'un ordre différent
peut-être bien sûr de la collecte de
données sans doute du stockage parce que
quand on s'intéresse à des jeunes un
jeune qui est transgressif notamment
dans un
sur ce type de média où il y a cette
incitation dans cinq ans il a Sciences
Po dans 10 ans il est dans un cabinet
ministériel est-ce que la Chine assez
capacités de stockage de traitement en
tous les cas elle est la capacité
d'identification des personnes en
fonction du comportement qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes filmés donc ce que je note
c'est la volonté alors on le voit moins
en Europe mais quand on vend en Amérique
du Nord notamment quand vous allez dans
les grands
magasins qui vendent du livre les
chaînes indigo ou autre maintenant vous
avez une table c'est la principale table
préconisée par tikt et ça devient à coup
de
renfort de publicité imprescripteur
important dans l'édition mais dans tout
un tas de domaines et moi je vois assez
bien la logique qui avait eu et qui a
toujours la Chine dans des domaines
c'est faire du dumping c'était le cas
sur un certain nombre de
matières premières les terres rares
c'est-à-dire un moment éliminer toute
concurrence avec des prix un peu élevés
puis une fois qu'on a le monopole on a
un autre usage il y a une deuxième étape
quand je dis de quoi Tik Tok est le nom
je peux pas m'empêcher de penser quand
même que ça fait partie d'une entreprise
dont le but n'est pas simplement la
bêtisement mais pousser des gens et des
jeunes à des comportements un peu hors
normes pour pouvoir avoir peut-être
demain des capacités de pression il y a
des capacités de pression directe la
censure la capitée la capacité
d'influence donc voilà moi je crois
quand même est-ce que on n'est pas dans
quelque chose qui est plus qu'une petite
partie du système je vous l'accorde
systémique d'influence chinois mais une
expérimentation extrêmement
large importantes et on va pas capter un
milliard de jeunes sur la planète avec
d'ailleurs des approches totalement
différentes en ce qui concerne la Chine
intérieure et le reste du monde sans un
projet à mon avis plus politique mais
peut-être que je vous dis c'est une
panorama une paranoïa anti-totalité qui
m'habite mais j'y vois quand même
quelque chose de plus que XM gafam ou
géant de l'Internet j'y vois un projet
peut-être plus large et dans les
déclarations qu'on lit de certains
dirigeants chinois tout ça n'a pas l'air
d'être totalement anodin
alors sur les élections je
pourra effectivement parler
[Musique]
ça en tout cas ça fait partie de la
stratégie ça veut pas dire que toute la
stratégie repose sur l'ingérence
électorale mais on a des cas aujourd'hui
très bien documentés d'ingérence
électorale dans plusieurs pays
occidentaux
qui montrent que c'est au moins un des
volets des des opérations d'influence de
la Chine sur
sur la stratégie globale de l'entreprise
c'est difficile à dire
moi j'essaye de
de n'affirmer que
[Musique]
les choses pour lesquelles j'ai des
preuves voilà quand j'ai pu collecter
des suffisamment d'éléments de matière
première pour affirmer quelque chose je
le fais sinon je préfère être un peu
prudent la votre hypothèse est plausible
bien évidemment mais pour l'instant on
en a pas la preuve on n'a pas la preuve
que ce serait un vaste plan voilà par
ailleurs j'ai quelques doutes parce que
[Musique]
globalement
le parti est pas forcément toujours très
efficace pour mettre en oeuvre de vastes
plantes ce type
en revanche il est très opportuniste
et ça il le fait très bien c'est à dire
que quand quelque chose fonctionne et
qu'il peut instrumentaliser ce quelque
chose ou l'utiliser à des fins qui sont
politiques même si le projet
originellement était purement commercial
ça le parti le fait sans état d'âme et
avec beaucoup d'efficacité mais ce qui
n'est déjà pas la même chose
pour nous à la limite peu importe vous
allez me dire le résultat c'est c'est ce
qui se passe sur Tik Tok mais du point
de vue du chercheur c'est quand même
important si on veut comprendre la
nature et le fonctionnement du du régime
là où vous avez raison c'est dans la
capacité de la Chine à voir à long terme
en tout cas on l'espèce
pas systématiquement ça veut pas dire
que tout projet est un projet à long
terme et des projets qui sont fait dans
l'urgence sans aucune réflexion qui ne
sont pas amenés à aux pensées pour durer
mais ils sont capables de le faire ils
sont capables de le faire et je vais
vous en donner une illustration
en fait on l'a remarqué dans tout
simplement dans les opérations de
recrutement
opérations de renseignements quand on
veut quand les Chinois veulent recruter
une source
quand on a un service de renseignement
travaille sur le court terme il va tout
de suite identifier la source qui peut
disposer des renseignements dont on a
besoin
l'ingénieur qui travaille chez
Thalès ou voilà imaginez ce que vous
voulez ou ou le le quelqu'un qui est
dans un cabinet ministériel ou etc
quand on vise sur le long terme on va
recruter des gens plus jeunes en misant
sur eux en espérant que peut-être un
jour ils auront des fonctions
utiles pour
pour la Chine et les Chinois font les
deux d'accord non seulement ils
recrutent directement des gens qui sont
déjà en fonction et qui disposent de
l'information dont ils ont besoin et ils
recrute aussi à long terme et donc on a
des cas
d'étudiants il y a par exemple un cas
qui a été rendu public par le FBI parce
que
l'intérêt des États-Unis c'est qu'il
judiciarise beaucoup les cas
d'espionnage et comme il judiciarise on
a accès à énormément d'informations et
sur cette base là on peut aujourd'hui
faire une espèce de cartographie de
typologie des modes opératoires des
services de renseignement chinois et il
y a un cas par exemple qui est celui de
glendes
américains qui était parti faire ses
études à Shanghai
qui a été recruté par le ministère de la
Sécurité d'État par une petite annonce
qui cherchait un étudiant américain pour
rédiger une petite étude insignifiante
sur je sais plus quel sujet c'était
l'économie américaine ou le
fonctionnement du du régime politique
étude extrêmement bien rémunéré qui a
été suivi d'une autre étude puis d'une
autre et puis la relation s'étend dans
la durée pendant plusieurs mois
la première personne au contact de
l'étudiant cède passe la main à notre
une autre personne qui est là souvent un
officier du MSE et puis et puis petit à
petit voilà les travaux deviennent plus
intéressants et à la fin que lui ont-ils
proposé et bien pour ta carrière ce
serait peut-être une bonne idée de
tenter le concours du Département d'État
ou de la CIA ce que donc cette étudiant
a fait il a échoué au département mais
il a réussi les les premières épreuves
pour le concours d'entrée à la CIA puis
il a été invité
détecteur de mensonges donc qui est
obligatoire quand on intègre la CIA aux
Etats-Unis et là il a un petit peu
paniqué quand on lui a demandé s'il
avait déjà perçu de l'argent d'une
puissance étrangère il a dit que
finalement il était plus candidat
et il a tenté de de retourner en Chine
et il a été arrêté au moment où il
prenait l'avion oui ça prêtait à prendre
l'avion voilà donc le fait que les
chinois les services de renseignement
chinois soient capables de recruter des
jeunes encore étudiants en espérant
qu'ils auront un jour des fonctions
intéressantes ou même encore mieux en
les incitant en les orientant vers ce
type de carrière vers les carrières qui
les intéressent montrent qu'ils sont
capables de de développer des stratégies
à long terme avec plus ou moins de
succès mais ils sont capables de le
faire c'est ça le régime mariste c'est
un régime qui est bâti alors il a une
disons qu'il a a c'est un peu Janus
quand il a deux visages le régime
maoïste il a un visage qui est
institutionnel et qui est qui essaye de
construire l'état si vous voulez et puis
là un visage qui est celui des
mobilisations populaires
on peut penser au grand bon en avant à
la Révolution culturelle etc toutes ces
fièvres populaires
c'est c'est typiquement c'est très
caractéristique du Maoris mais et ce que
fait siping aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ça
donc bon voilà c'est une petite une
petite différence mais ça permet parfois
de pas commettre des rares d'analyses
donc oui il y a un échec stratégique
pardon
il y a un échec stratégique en effet
comme vous l'avez rappelé parce que même
si la Chine est capable de remporter un
certain nombre de succès tactiques ici
ou là avec plusieurs opérations qui ont
très très bien fonctionné et donc il y
aura apporté des gains à court terme
sur le moyen terme disons on assiste à
un effondrement de l'image de la Chine
dans le monde
l'exemple le plus fragrance flagrant
c'est celui de la Corée du Sud il y a 20
ans
la Chine avait 69% d'image positives en
Corée du Sud on est tombé à 19%
aujourd'hui
et tout simplement parce que les Chinois
ont le Parti communiste a une posture
beaucoup plus agressive vis-à-vis de la
Corée comme elle là vis-à-vis de
l'Europe vis-à-vis de l'Amérique du Nord
etc la nuance que l'on pourrait apporter
à
cette évaluation
c'est les succès malgré tout que la
Chine remporte dans le sud global et là
aussi ce n'est pas on peut faire une
comparaison avec ce que je viens de dire
pour la France c'est pas par adhésion au
régime chinois mais par
antioxydantalisme ou anti-américanisme
parfois ça dépend de la même manière que
les les un certain nombre de pays qui
ont
qui se laissent séduire disons par les
Russes et Wagner c'est parfois plus
parce par par rejet de la France que par
adhésion au modèle russe c'est important
parce que ça veut dire que la réponse
n'est pas forcément la même c'est-à-dire
que vis-à-vis il y a une réponse qu'il
faut apporter à la Chine on doit mettre
en place un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour nous protéger contre
ces opérations informationnelles mais
ensuite il y a une réponse peut-être
dans plus diplomatique à apporter aussi
vis-à-vis de ces pays qui se laissent
séduire par
la proposition de de
rééquilibre mondial que propose la Chine
ce que la Chine propose c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'un révisionnisme international
et le parti le dit très clairement si le
dit très clairement si on prend la peine
de les lire ce qu'ils veulent c'est
refonder refonder le système
international pour qu'il ressemble plus
au système chinois et qu'il défendent
mieux les intérêts de la Chine
et la l'offensive vers vers le sud
global elle relève de cette de cette
logique et on doit devrait se méfier
de pas trop s'isoler nous de ce Sud
global au risque de le voir prendre
parti pour pour Pékin regardez ce qui se
passe à l'ONU au sein du Comité des
droits de l'homme on a complètement
perdu on a perdu c'est les régimes
autoritaires aujourd'hui qui domine les
débats sur les droits de l'homme au sein
de l'ONU pourquoi parce qu'ils sont plus
nombreux
et cette rhétorique là la Chine l'avance
en permanence c'est-à-dire que même dans
le vote sur les sanctions de la Russie
pour l'invasion de l'Ukraine voilà ils
ont mis en avant le fait que certes une
majorité d'État a voté en faveur des
sanctions mais les 50 ou 45 étages et
puis exactement qui ont voté contre où
se sont abstenus représente plus de la
moitié de la population mondiale
ça c'est un argument auquel on ne sait
pas répondre alors bien sûr c'est
rhétorique ces populations là c'est pas
les populations qui votent c'est les
gouvernements etc mais pour l'instant on
n'est pas capable de répondre à ce type
d'argumentation on le fait très mal là
c'est un enjeu colossal
est-ce que du coup ça affaiblit le
régime enfin est-ce qu'il y a un
affaiblissement potentiel du régime oui
mais c'est une question à laquelle c'est
il est extrêmement difficile de répondre
on peut absolument pas dire si j'ai une
régime est sur le point de s'effondrer
ou pas mais en gardant l'esprit ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
je peux absolument pas vous dire oui le
régime va s'effondrer dans les cinq ans
ou 10 ans à venir ou non c'est
impossible qui s'effondre mais s'il
s'effondre je serai pas surpris
[Musique]